[Music]
the world was watching when the verdict
came down in derek chovan's murder trial
and students were paying attention to
yesterday we introduced you to high
schoolers in mount vernon new york who
were following the trial in class they
shared their thoughts about justice and
racism
both before and after the guilty verdict
i was almost about to cry because there
was a chance that
he wasn't going to be found guilty and
there was nothing like anyone could do
about it
but i do feel like relieved now and like
this is not
the end nor the beginning of our fight
at all
because i'm a good christian so i don't
want to be happy of
people's misfortune but i was kind of
happy that
he's gonna pay for what he did the
students in e3 english at mount vernon
high school
in new york have strong opinions about
the guilty verdict in the trial of
former minneapolis police officer derek
shovin
we've been spending over an hour now
talking about and watching this
their class has been studying the trial
intently and
everyone both in person and those who
joined by zoom
already believed that chauvin was guilty
based mostly on what they saw in the now
infamous video he looks like angry like
he looks like aggravated like he looks
like he actually wants to do it and like
to do what
like to kill him like it looks like he
wants to hurt him
and it's just so like sad
just to see this like people treating
human beings like this just because of
their color
i wanted to know what you all felt about
race in this particular case
specifically with george floyd
and derek shoving i could already
imagine how this would have went down
if george ford was white there wouldn't
be that much aggression
i wasn't surprised on how the police
reacted to george floyd it was a sad yes
but i wasn't surprised about what
happened i definitely think it would
have been different
if george was white i would say it's
about race
because i can't really think of another
way to say it
let's hope there's justice you hope that
there's justice
yeah what does justice look like for you
i feel like he should like go to jail he
should go to jail
he should learn he should learn his
lesson
when the guilty verdicts were handed
down the students we spoke with believed
that justice had been served at least
for now
does what happened today give you some
sense of hope that
there can be justice here in the u.s i'm
not sure because
it was just one case it happened in just
one case because
in every other cases i've heard of the
police officers walked away free
so um i'm not i kind of oh i kind of
have some hope
that it's going to actually change
something evelyn how are you feeling
after hearing that verdict the guilty
verdict
like well amino said earlier
it felt wrong for me to feel good that
he was found guilty
because you know nobody deserves to be
in life for prison but at the same time
at least he was held responsible
i think that now people are awakening
and they're finally
you know they're facing justice the way
that it was meant to be
they were informed they were curious
they were compassionate
i was so grateful as a student of
history that our ep shawna thomas gave
me this assignment to witness this
moment
of history with these young people
because we know how transformative
moments like this in history can be 15
year old john lewis
bearing witness to 14 year old emmett
till people who joined the public
service after kennedy was assassinated
or joined the military after 9 11 they
will go on to change the world
and it was one of their own who led the
change 17 year old darnell
that's right you know one thing it's you
talked about it yesterday but of those
things that you
you mentioned they all they were the
compassionate part was the
i admit that was the part that surprised
me because i kids often get angry and
really passionate the compassion is
sometimes comes they talked about derek
shelvin's family well
it's amazing the same care for humanity
in george floyd
leads them to care for the humanity of
derek chovin and we await
any comment from mr chauvin himself
about recognizing what condition he's in
and where he goes from here we'll be
looking for that vlad thank you very
much